un teatro tiene un total de 63 asientos
arreglados en un rectángulo son nueve
filas cada una con el mismo número de
asientos cuántos asientos habrá en total
se añadimos dos asientos por fila
podemos decir que tenemos un total
de asientos
y ese total de asientos en este momento
son 63 de los cuales ya contamos con
ellos
más los nuevos asientos vamos a ponerle
aquí nuevos
cómo sabemos cuántos asientos nuevos
pues simplemente aquí nos están dando la
información nos dicen que son nueve
filas
y que sumaremos dos asientos por cada
fila
vamos a poner entonces que nuestro total
realmente sera
dos asientos nuevos
por las nueve filas que tenemos esos
eran nuestros asientos nuevos si a esos
asientos nuevos nosotros le sumamos los
63 originales vamos a tener entonces el
total de asientos de nuestro teatro
que finalmente es la pregunta que nos
están haciendo cuántos asientos habrá en
total si añadimos dos por fila
vamos a hacer un poco más despacio
perfecto cuando ustedes vean este tipo
de operaciones donde tenemos en una sola
fila sumas y multiplicaciones primero
haremos las multiplicaciones y las
divisiones y en este caso tiene sentido
porque primero sacaremos los lugares
nuevos más adelante lo veremos en otros
vídeos con respecto al orden de
operaciones sin embargo en este momento
simplemente por el color sabemos qué
haremos primero estos 29 por 2
y tenemos el total de 63 originales
vamos a hacer algo vamos a poner
visualmente dos asientos en cada una de
las filas les parecen dos lugares nuevos
cuatro lugares
y estos serán los dos de la tercera fila
dos más en la cuarta fila
dos más en la quinta fila
dos más en la sexta fila
pero estos son los dos de la séptima
fila
octava fila
y novena fila perfecto tenemos entonces
los nuevos asientos cuántos fueron 2 4 6
8 10 12 14 16 18 2 x 9 de nuestras
tablas de multiplicar será igual a 18 ya
los contamos aquí sí serán 18 entonces
los nuevos asientos colocaremos los 63
originales y podemos hacer la suma para
tener el total vamos a escribir el total
tenemos entonces 63 18 vamos a sumar eso
y tendremos qué
18 3 es igual a 21 21
+ 60 es igual a 81 o de hecho lo podemos
ver de otra manera 83 es igual a 11 60
más 10 es igual a 70 y los 11 que
teníamos es igual a 81 de cualquier
manera y con esto tenemos entonces
nuestro resultado final el total de
asientos que ahora tendrán nuestro
teatro
será igual a 81